so basically being a new leader
overcoming friction in the new
organization that's this that's what
this guy it's easier you know he's a new
leader overcoming friction in any
penetrating insight yes and I think
what's important here is this is he's
not a new leader like newly commissioned
leader stepping up in the ranks he's a
new in a new organization so he's
stepping into a new leader in a new
situation
yeah we've kind of talked about stepping
up from within the organization how do
you go in and step into a new
organization now I'm gonna look at this
from a perspective of like a normal
transition into a leadership position
and a new job or something like that
not a hostile takeover situation maybe
we can address that on a later time but
not a situation where hey they fired
this guy he had a bad reputation the
things are going wrong you're gonna step
in and change it because that that would
take a different leadership approach
than the one that I would that I would
take and that I have taken where you're
stepping in a situation where things are
going okay and you put you're coming in
and you've got some goals and there's so
you're taking over leadership position
it happens all the time so a couple
things about this first of all you step
into a new leadership role you got to
talk to people but you mostly gotta
listen you gotta find out why they're
doing things the way they are because a
lot of times there might be reasons for
the way things are happening that you
don't understand or that aren't really
particularly evident so you really want
to not make the judgments because you're
bringing your own experience and you've
done this a thousand times and that's
why you're the new leader and that's why
they put you in here you gotta set that
aside and say okay explain to me why
this process is in place or where did
this process come from what is this
process trying to prevent so that way
you're getting smarter and you're
learning and you're not being you're not
imposing your ideas which you don't have
any background for you don't you know
you may have been a leadership in a
different
company or a different unit before and
you think you know but you don't know so
be humble and check yourself you gotta
be friendly to people but at the same
time you gotta be reserved no this is
this is tricky because you are trying to
build relationships you absolutely are
trying to build relations that's what
life is that's what business is that's
what war is that's what everything is
about building relationships with these
other humans so you want to be friendly
to people but at the same time from a
leadership perspective you can't just
come in and be mr. nice guy and best
friends with everybody that's not gonna
work out for you for a couple reasons
number one you don't know the the face
that people are gonna present you out of
the gate is not necessarily the true
face of that person so you may check in
your first day this guy hey it's great
to meet you so good to have you on board
heard a lot about you and you go wow
this guy's and he starts giving you some
background information about things that
are going and by the way we got a couple
things are a little messed up you know
and I can point them out to you but that
guy might be working his agenda so you
gotta be cautious whereas you go in and
the other piece of that is it is much
easier to reel back in slack or sorry
it's much easier to give out that
friendship later then it is if you go
overboard and you become everyone's best
friend and now you got to cut it off
yeah all of a sudden you become a jerk
yeah so it's much easier to to give out
the slack when you want to later than it
is to give out a bunch of slack and then
try and reel it back in and be a jerk
yeah and it makes it hard for both
parties that's why yeah like but it's
gonna be really hard the only reason
you're pulling back the friendship thing
is because it started going sideways and
that makes it even harder and it's a
nightmare gotta watch out for the gossip
cuz everyone's gonna want to whisper in
your hair the things about the things
about the people and this and that so
you gotta be careful nod your head take
it and bow on boy
but take it with a grain of salt
definitely don't encourage it
yeah and that can be a hard part for
certain types of people will say because
let's face it man that can be some
interesting stuff yeah there could be
some knowledge to be gained there but
you just have to be careful you want to
hear some insights right but be careful
when the insights cross over into gossip
yeah yeah and be careful that the
insights are coming from people that
might have agendas in fact they are
coming from people that have agendas
because everybody has agendas and maybe
the person has a positive agenda which
is to improve the company or improve the
unit or improve the team but they also
might have a agenda of improving their
own station in life so you have to be
careful of that they are watching you
they are watching you when you come in
to take over they are watching you so
act accordingly think about the fact
that they are watching you like I said
use caution and forming these new
relationships you gotta find out who's
who you want to establish things but
again you gotta watch out because people
might not necessarily be who they make
themselves out to be in the beginning so
this is kind of becoming a little bit of
a chorus when I talk about leading be
humble listen learn move methodically
when it does come time to make change in
a new situation most of the time I would
say do it incrementally do smaller
changes after you've assessed fully and
you've got people up it got people's
opinions and you've expressed and
socialized your ideas so you're not
trying to roll in there and change the
world again now if we go into a hostile
turnover situation or there's someone's
been fired for cause or that's a
different situation but for a normal
transition into a new job be humble
listen learn and lead that part where
you're talking about find out why
they're doing the things that the way
they are and stuff
that that part can be depending on
certain people's personality like you
were coming in as the new guy and you
and you asked start asking hey why do
you guys do it like this if you come off
with the wrong tone sometimes it'll
sound like that you're questioning it
for sure you know so if I remember when
I worked at the nightclub we had a new
manager and his name was Joel he uh he
came in and he was strangely he was this
whole list personified he came in is
really friendly but really reserved but
the one thing he did kind of to address
was really good job me except no no no
okay nothing I'm saying an example of
how he clarified that he's not
questioning the way we're doing stuff
he's not saying hey why are you doing it
like that because this way sucks it
didn't have that tone but he came to me
and I saw him do it to the other guy um
where he he came and said hey I'm gonna
be asking a lot of questions because
obviously I'm new here you know just so
I can understand and get on board with
what you're doing so it can be
ultimately what we are doing that's what
he said he said in a little bit
differently obviously but that's what he
said and that right away so no matter
what question he asked it was almost
like shoot I want to tell this guy how
it's working nice you know cuz he's
Jesus he's on my team automatically he
told me that and he was on my team so I
think if that can be clarified that
you're not like questioning it because
it seems like you know I want to make it
seem like um you know I know a better
way right off the bat you don't want
that tone you know I know just from her
on the receiving end I don't want that
don't know because I'm gonna be on yeah
so anyway yes yes in the last thing I
had written down here was enjoy it it's
it's it's awesome stepping into a new
leadership position and it's challenging
to do what you just talked about to
transition people in to your leadership
realm and to do it in a subtle way that
brings them on board with a positive
attitude so enjoy that challenge yeah
cuz it's it's pretty fun it's
challenging and most importantly it's
rewarding yeah